hey this is pressure Locker you have a
fair coin that shows heads 50% of the
time and tails 50% of the time you and a
friend play a coin flipping game can you
create a rule classifying the coin flips
so that you win with probability exactly
equal to P and your friend wins with
probability exactly equal to one minus P
the probability can be any rational or
irrational number between 0 & 1 the game
has to end in a finite number of coin
flips with probability 1 can you figure
it out you can also try this extension
to the problem now you have a coin that
shows heads with probability Q between 0
& 1
but unfortunately the value Q is unknown
to you in other words you have a biased
coin but you don't know the bias can you
now figure out a game where you win with
probability P the value of P is known to
you the same restrictions apply the game
has to end in a finite number of coin
flips with probability 1 can you figure
out these problems give them a try and
when you're ready keep watching the
video for the solution let's get started
with some examples imagine you wanted to
win a game with probability 3/4 one way
to do this is you could imagine flipping
the coin 2 times this generates four
equally likely sequences of coin tosses
we can classify three of those sequences
as a win for you and one of those
sequences as a loss for you this will be
a game in which you win 3/4 of the time
now imagine instead you wanted to win a
game with probability 1/3 we can
slightly modify this procedure we have 4
coin tosses what we do is we class
if I wanted them as a win two of them as
a loss and we say the third sequence two
tails in row we can just classify that
as disregard these two tosses and start
all over so flip two times again and we
again have the same rules on what you do
with the coin tosses you will win this
game with probability 1/3 we can
generalize this procedure imagine you
wanted to win a game with probability X
over Y you would need to flip the coin
just enough times so that you get to a
value that's more than Y we can then
classify X of the sequences as a win we
can classify Y minus X of the sequences
as a loss and then we can classify the
rest of the sequences as starting over
just disregard them and start over
according to the same rules you will win
this game with the probability of x over
y but what if you wanted to win a game
with probability one divided by PI now
since 1 over pi is irrational we cannot
write it exactly as x over y for
integers X and y so this procedure is
not going to be easily modified to
figure out things where we need an
irrational probability so we're going to
use a different procedure the solution
is to use binary numbers so we'll write
the probability P in terms of its binary
expansion so this will be a sequence of
fractions that are powers of two this
can be written as zero point b1 b2 b3
and so on so just like we write decimal
numbers these are going to be fractional
numbers that are in binary
each of these fractional numbers b1 b2
these represent powers of 1/2 so how is
this going to be useful for us
I'll give some examples of binary
numbers so we have the fraction 1/2 this
can be written as 1/2 plus 0 over 2 to
the power of 2 plus 0 over 2 to the
power of 3 and so on so in binary form
this will be 0 point 1 and then there
will be zeros after that the number one
third will be written as point zero one
zero one
repeating it'll be 0 1 0 1 and so on 1
over pi also will have a binary
expansion this will go on forever but
there is a binary expansion to this
number so how is this going to help us
we have the probability in its binary
form here's the game we're going to
define flip a coin until it lands on
heads for the first time let's say
that's toss number n the rule of the
game is that if B sub n equals 1 you win
the game if B sub n equals 0 then you
lose the game so for example let's say
the probability is 1/3 this will be 0 1
0 1 and so on you win if the first time
the coin shows heads is on an even
number toss 2 4 6 et cetera and you lose
the game otherwise so how come this game
has a probability of 1/3 of you winning
the game let's prove that it always has
a probability of P the probability you
win the game is the probability that the
first heads shows on toss number K times
the value of the binary digit in the
value K so the probability that you get
the first heads showing on toss K is 1
over 2 to the power of K and the
probability that the binary digit is
equal to 1 in that spot is exactly the
binary digit because the binary digit in
spot K is either going to be 0 or 1
what we have is we have come up with
exactly the binary representation of P
therefore the probability you win this
game is exactly equal to P so there's
another way you can use binary numbers
to create a game in which you win with
probability P we start out with our
binary representation of P we now do
something slightly different for each
flip of the coin we record a 1 if we
flipped a heads and we record a 0 if we
flipped tails we are going to keep
flipping the coin as long as flip K
equals the binary digit of K once we get
to a point where the flip differs say
that's toss n we're going to define that
you win the game if your flip was tails
and you're going to lose the game if the
flip was heads so why does this
procedure work let's go through the
example where P is equal to 1/3 we have
our binary representation so here's how
the game would work let's imagine we
flip tails heads heads the first two
digits 0 1 are the same as the 0 1 in
1/3 but that third value in 1/3 is equal
to 0 and we flipped a heads on our last
one which was different so we're going
to stop flipping after this third flip
and the last flip we had was a heads so
we differed and it was a heads so we're
going to define this as a loss if
instead we flipped tails tails that
would mean our second toss was different
from the binary expansion of 1/3 and in
this case the last flip differed as the
tails so in this case we would win the
game so this may sound like a strange
procedure but there's an intuitive way
to see why
works intuitively the coin flips will
define a random number Z that's between
0 & 1 if this number Z that we get to by
flipping ends up being less than P we
are winning the game and if it's more
than P we lose the game so basically
we're creating with our coin flips a
random number between 0 & 1 and if this
number ends up being in the interval 0
to P we're going to win
so we win this game with probability P
here's a graphical way to see what's
going on in this game we start out with
our interval 0 1 let's suppose we have a
probability of P of 1/3 so we're saying
the winning interval is numbers that end
up between 0 and 1/3
now the first toss of our coin suppose
it's a heads so we know that our number
Z is going to start out with 0.1 well a
number that starts out 0.1 is going to
define something between 1/2 and 1 it's
going to at least be 1/2 because 0.1
means we're adding 1/2 to whatever
remains so if our first toss is a heads
we're going to end up in something
that's larger than one-third and there's
no way that we could end up in the
interval between 0 and 1/3 so our number
differs in the very first spot and it
differs to be larger so we're going to
lose the game for sure let's suppose we
continued where the first toss was the
tails this instead would define a number
between 0 and 1/2 we can never get a
number larger than 1/2 because the first
spot in our expansion of Z is equal to
point zero so in order to see where Z
ends up we're going to have to flip
again so let's say at this point we flip
tails so a point 0 0 so now we're going
to define an interval that's actually
between 0
1/4 Z has to be less than 1/4 from its
form furthermore we have a number Z or
that second digit 0 0 that's differing
from the second digit of P but in this
case the differing digit is a tails so
we know that we are going to win this
game for sure to give one more example
suppose that we had tosses of tails
heads heads now the first time we
differed was the third toss however we
differed by being a heads so we actually
ended up in an interval that's larger
than one-third so we're going to lose
this game for sure so now let's tackle
the extension we have a biased coin that
shows with probability heads with
probability Q how can we solve the game
now what we're going to do is we're
going to make a fair toss from the
biased coin we're going to flip the
biased coin two times this creates four
possible different tosses we don't know
the probability of each of these tosses
but we're going to classify them as
follows we're going to say if you toss
two heads or two tails just disregard
that outcome and start over if however
you tossed heads tails classify that as
a heads and if you clap tossed tails
heads classify that as a tails so while
we don't know the exact probability of
these outcomes we can calculate their
theoretical probability because we know
the coin shows heads with probability Q
so if we wanted so the probability of
heads will be tossing a heads followed
by a tails so this will be Q times 1
minus Q the probability of tossing a
tails will be the probability of tossing
T followed by H so this will be 1 minus
Q times Q what you'll notice here is
that the probability of HT is exactly
equal to the probability of th
in other words we have a game which ends
with heads or tails exactly 50% of the
time for each of those two cases the
probability of heads is equal to the
probability of tails in other words we
have made a fair coin out of a biased
coin so now the problem reduces so what
do we do if we have a fair coin and we
need to win the game with probability P
well we've just solved that problem we
can use one of the binary number
procedures that have just been described
and we can get to a game which we win
with probability P so it's an absolutely
stunning result we can simulate any
probability P that we want rational or
irrational from a coin and it can be a
biased coin where we don't even know the
bias did you figure out this problem
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel I make videos on
math and game theory you can catch from
my blog mind your decisions you can
follow on Facebook Google+ and patreon
you can catch me on social media at
pressure Locker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description